YEN-JIE LEE: Yeah, so I
think a sense of humor
is really a very, very
good tool in the teaching.
So I usually insert interesting
figures in my slides.
Then people will
be really focusing
on your slides and your
lecture because people
don't want to miss the joke.
Right?
And also, that makes the
lecture much more enjoyable
as well because everybody
wants to learn things happily.
Right?
And also, those jokes I
insert, most of the time,
they are relevant to physics
interpretation of those jokes.
So that's actually my idea
to make the lecture much more
enjoyable, and also keeping
the students very focused
on the material we cover.
So my idea is to have a much
more relaxed classroom so that
you can actually-- then people
will feel that they can ask
whatever question they
have because I'm not, like,
super serious, I mean, asking
for everybody to keep quiet
and cannot react to any funny
things that I have been doing.
From here, actually,
Maxwell see the light.
[LAUGHTER]
Can you see it?
Maybe not yet.
Maybe we are slightly
slower than Maxwell.
But-- but we will see that
together in this lecture.
First of all, I will
feel very relaxed
because I can do whatever I
want to help the students.
And also, the students
will feel that their stress
of asking questions
were greatly reduced
if the instructor is actually
very funny, and very,
very humorous.
So that's actually my idea,
which drive me to the decision
to insert a lot of interesting
pictures and the jokes
during the lecture.